hey man it's me kevin smith uh i asked a
bunch of people on twitter
hit me up with your questions uh on
masters of the universe
revelation coming to netflix july 23rd
and uh they hit me with a bunch of
questions so i'm going to scroll through
and answer them as quickly as i can but
mind you
i i got long answers i'm very
long-winded
uh hank ronson wants to know what was it
like to meet the man the legend the
great alan
oppenheimer absolute honor i took
pictures with him that day when he came
in
uh talked to him it was very important
for us to have alan
in the show um obviously he didn't get
to play
skeletor although you hear him in
episode one
um if you listen closely you'll hear
alan oppenheimer
doing a doing a cameo at the very end of
the episode
you'll you'll hear it um but
this is a man who's been involved with a
storied franchise that
all of us working on on revelation you
know
he's got the most time on it and uh he's
such a
lovely guy wonderful guy very funny
uh tons of stories for days and moving
stuff too we brought him into the uh
masters of the universe uh revelation
revelations
after show that will be on uh on netflix
after our our episodes
and he tells a very moving story about
like somebody who is like you know
that show stopped me from committing
suicide um so he's
absolutely the best what a what a
wonderful gentleman
um okay dodge mega says does the 2002
reboot factor in at all or is it now
ignored
it's not so much ignored as we can't
really touch it let me explain
uh masters the universe is has many
parents
so to speak mattel birthed it in 1981
they created masters of the universe
which includes e-man
tila man at arms uh the sorceress
uh skeletor evelyn all the original toys
then more authors joined the party when
dc comics starts uh doing their masters
universe line of comic books
dc comics is responsible for inventing
prince adam
the other side the alt you know the uh
the uh
alter ego if you will of he-man uh why
because dc comics that's what they do
batman superman all their heroes have a
secret identity
so they approach t-man the same way like
he's also got a secret identity it's
when he picks that sword up and says
something
that's when he becomes he-man so that
wasn't even invented
you know by mattel it's not part of the
mattel lure for the figures
that came in the comics and then it was
translated over to the filmation
cartoons the filmation cartoons add more
spokes to the legacy they create orco um
and other things as well so there's a
lot of parents a lot of hands on this
then in 2002 as mentioned there was the
great mike young productions version of
the show
that was very true to all the characters
and whatnot
but that version uh just like the
filmation version
is not owned by mattel or netflix
obviously ours is a mattel television
production and it's airing on netflix so
we can't touch some elements
that belong to other people who hold
those other copyrights for example
universal owns the copyright and all the
episodes of he-man and the masters of
the universe the filmation show they
have the filmation library
so we weren't going to be using the song
because it belongs you know the open e
man it belongs to
universal and that would have required
you know actually
negotiating putting up loot for it and
plus you know bear wanted to do
a score a real score just like you know
we're homaging
the the the filmation version spiritual
sequel but not a
direct sequel if you will so at that
point we knew
that um there you know there's certain
things we can't
touch because they're not ours to play
with
so the the 2002 version of masters
universe the mike young productions
um we couldn't play with any of their
elements any of their story lines
uh because they weren't mattel's
storylines they belong to the company
that made that cartoon and whoever
holds all those cartoons so ours was
always meant to be
the toys predicated on the mattel lore
which is very rich they had mini comics
they set up
you know a lot of the franchise they set
up mostly everything you know about
masters of the universe
so we stuck with that like we you know
it's a mattel television production so
naturally mattel was like
do the real version of of masters
universe which is our version of masters
of the universe
so we don't get to touch on that but i
urge anybody who loves masters universe
to go check out
uh the mike young productions uh version
of the show it was i hope i'm saying
that right right and not mistaking the
name
as a stoner at elmo's age 51
names and dates like some cat on the
internet was like you said that you
watched this in 1981 and it didn't come
out of tv until 1983.
and i was like well maybe or perhaps i'm
just a 51 year old man who
for about 25 years of his life referred
to
uh the empire strikes back one of his
favorite films ever made
as a 1979 motion picture even though
as i found out later on it came out in
1980
like i smoke a lot of weed kids don't
don't crush my nuts if i say 1981 versus
1980 [ __ ] three
columbo there's no proof of [ __ ]
anything other than like
he's old but if you've not seen that
version of
masters universe go watch it they did a
wonderful wonderful job
okay um
faking insanity says how much pressure
did you feel in adding to such an iconic
media presence
huge you know normally i work on jay and
sal and bob and there's no pressure
because it's like well i just
i created it you know so there's no like
i gotta live up to the legacy i'm like i
gotta live up to the jackass who created
it and i am that jackass so
no there's generally not a lot of
pressure in the writing that i do
because they're my characters and you're
not playing with somebody else's toys
but this
i'm playing with masters of the universe
i'm literally playing with somebody
else's toys mattel's toys
so there's a huge amount of pressure
going in i didn't want to be one of
those people it's like everything you
know about
masters of the universe is wrong i'm
going to reinvent it they didn't ask for
a reinvention
they were like we want something that is
going to play to the fans
like the hardcore fans people who grew
up watching the cartoon collected the
toys
this is for them and we think you're the
guy because you worked on your daredevil
comics and your
green arrow comics rob was saying he's
like that to me says you're the guy
so if they had come to me and said we
want you to reinvent this you know the
way that they did
reinvent shira i would have been like
i'm not your guy
i'm so not creative or inventive but if
in a world where they were like we want
you to keep going
to tell the next story like what happens
if these cats all grew up and someone
died i'd be like i
i was like i could definitely do that i
could tell that story
so i felt the pressure and i we
approached it the way
marvel approaches we took the marvel
method we said marvel cinematic universe
method
which is uh i loved all those stories
growing up reading them in comic books
and now i love them again as they're
fed back to me with new recipes spruced
up as movies and stuff like that so
the idea here was the same thing like
we're not just vowing any part of the
the lure um it all plays it's all real
we're just
augmenting to it add another spy spoke
to the wheel
not reinvent the wheel by any stretch of
the imagination so if you want something
reinvented don't come to kevin smith
but if you want something lovingly
sequalized you know almost devotedly so
i was i was definitely the right person
for the job
i feel like okay um
can't canada or xbox canada says how
nervous
were you about how the fandom would
react to you
executing your ideas for the new
season um i mean
not very i mean i honestly like we have
the two biggest fans in the world
working on the show so our exec netflix
ted biaselle
like the only reason this exists is
because ted loved the show as a kid and
he was like i always dreamed they would
do
a version that's like grown up where
like people could die
and there are stakes and stuff so
we had him at netflix and then we had
the great rob david at mattel television
rob is a very funny guy he should be on
stage um he's got a quick wit
but he's also a writer as well so he
doesn't just run like mattel television
and stuff
he's he's writing like the other masters
of the universe
he man and the master of the universe
show the cartoon show that they're doing
on netflix as well
um and he wrote the masters of the
universe comics
like for dc for the last few years so
like rob is steeped in the lure
so between those two titans like we
called ourselves the three towers of
paternia
i could not fail i wasn't worried about
the reaction of the audience because i
knew who the audience was i was working
for the audience like
teddy represented the exact customer we
were trying to reach
and then in the process of making it you
realize oh we can expand it it doesn't
have to just be for fans
because we know every fan is going to
bring their kid to the table be like
this is what i watched when i was a kid
so you know we made it more accessible
to not just you know it wasn't so deep
cuts that only
hardcore fans could understand it
anybody could enter into the episodes
and pretty much
follow along what's going on and enjoy
it and stuff
so i never felt scared i was never like
what's the audience gonna say
because i knew who the audience was it
was teddy and teddy
loved every step of the way and if he
didn't love something he made it
so that way he did love it he'd be like
can we do this can we add this like oh
my god yeah
great like you know marlena an episode
uh it ain't i want you
spoilers you'll see teddy teddy
um knowing that he since we had his sign
off for everything
i was never worried about the audience
seeing it because i'm like if that guy
likes it
everybody's going to like it if you love
masters universe
if you're a true master's universe fan a
lot of posers out there a lot of people
like i watched that when i was a kid man
and you're doing it wrong
they didn't watch every episode i assure
you i did
in the 80s i was not like a hardcore
like god [ __ ] i love this [ __ ] you know
i made fun of it a lot because i was 13
years old and i was like this is for
babies
they don't even fight nobody gets
stabbed but i watched every episode
because back then there was no
nothing on tv we didn't have cable we
didn't have the [ __ ] internet so you
watched what was on
so i i watched every episode of masters
of the universe and there's a lot of
people who are like
you don't know anything about math who
literally have not watched every episode
of the series
because they were born like 20 years
later and stuff so
i felt very safe particularly with rob
and teddy
on my side and i knew what we were doing
was reverential and loving so
honestly i was never really worried
about the audience uh reaction
especially powerhouse animation had our
backs man
like you know even if the scripts were
stupid powerhouse made a beautiful
looking [ __ ] show so i
never never sweated um
uh joe starr's sister meg's jedi says
uh did your eyes pop when you saw the
new animation style
absolutely um uh the you know boys at
powerhouse and the girls but our two
directors pat and adam
they uh they found a way to
you know just draw what we all know and
just make it look
cooler you know there was no reinvention
of the wheel yes there's a part in our
story
where we take a bit of a time jump and
so characters change appearance a little
bit some of them do
but generally speaking everybody looks
exactly as they did
back in the 80s in every iteration and
their action figures
that's you know that's what mattel
wanted that's why it's funny like people
online going like
you're gonna mess it up do you think
mattel would have hired me to mess it up
they're in the toy selling business
and they want to sell toys man so like
they
they made sure that this was exactly
what they wanted it to be
uh as well so our eyes collectively
popped when we saw the artwork
we didn't know back then that there
would be figures for sure
we didn't we knew that mattel would be
doing he-man figures we didn't know if
they would do them based on revelation
but they like the artwork so much that
instantly they move toward making
the master verse figures which are out
right now you can get a he-man
evil lynn skeletor uh moss man or
skelegod
five different figures that are out
right now um not a tila
you know for everybody that's like this
is a good show
if it's a tila show we should have put
tila and wave one of the figures if
that's the case but
this is a masters of the universe show
not a tila show not a he-man show
masters of the universe full cast of
characters ladies and gentlemen
uh okay ralph hartman asks
will buzz-off and mechanic be on the
series
yes and no and i'll just leave it at
that
i trust you're intrigued uh
doug lee fan says
favorite part what a great question my
favorite part of this process
has been the entire [ __ ] process um
working with everybody you know coming
up with cool ideas watching it come to
life
watching other people take my [ __ ] make
it better just because i come up with
the whole story doesn't mean that like
that story
like didn't get better by being touched
by so many different hands the writers
the directors
so the collaborative effort and seeing
material every week like every week they
would send me a batch of like here's
some new drawings or here's an animatic
or here's the first animated uh sequence
and
you know it's just pure joy or then
recording hanging out with
like cool famous people doing amazing
voices for like some goofy dialogue that
i wrote and stuff
so all that was great but i think my
favorite part of this process was
uh throughout the pandemic i was just i
was so up in
motu's grill all the time so in the
morning i'd get up smoke a joint sit
down and be like well
if i didn't have writing to do or
anything to do that you know schedule
wise
and i had free time that's how i filled
my free time i didn't watch other
people's stuff i didn't like watch
movies or anything
i was like you know what like sometimes
i'd be watching movies in my room and be
like i think master's universe is more
gratifying than
and come down here and i would watch the
animatics all the way through
like episodes one through five and then
when they were fully animated same thing
because once it starts going you just
want to keep going you just want to keep
reading and stuff like that
so i was very into
um my alone time with masters of the
universe
writing was great as always it's very
fun to create and stuff but
you know getting footage back and being
able to just watch it
over and over and that would help you
improve future episodes and you know
hearing like
let's swap out that line of dialogue and
so
you know it that to me was the best part
um the performances are absolutely
[ __ ] mind
mind-bendingly wonderful um
you know uh uh chris
woody um sarah mark
and and uh lena you know steven root as
our cringer uh
liam cunningham tiffany smith like
they're they're
so wonderful they worked so well
together
and gave such honest performances for
you know a pretty dishonest
concept there are no talking green cats
in the world kids
okay chris coppiar says
orco looks to have leveled up to a
badass status
how have you modernized some of these
characters personalities
to fit in the 2021 world but stay true
to form now
what a great question um remember
they're not in the 2021 world they are
they're in eternia so it's a fantasy
land and so we don't necessarily have to
play
how the world is today that's why it's
crazy everyone online is like this is
all woken it's all politics like
this [ __ ] show with the talking green
cat in it man like
how political you think we're gonna get
there's no sex in this [ __ ]
it's no politics it's just good old
adventure just like people who are like
people who really like each other
trying to help each other that's one of
my favorite aspects of this show i was
like these characters
genuinely like one another there's human
warmth
between these two-dimensional cartoons
and so
um you know if we didn't
have to like bring it into 2021
we just had to add steaks and to add
steaks
you just have to add death or
peril like real peril not like in the
old show where it's like
hey man i'm trapped and he's like the
sword will and then peril's gone
you know you take you take somebody out
somebody got
somebody goes you know you've you've
you then got the audience attention
going wait a second
you know death is possible in this world
i had no idea and stuff so
at that point when we were in the
writers room putting together the series
you know we looked at the the orco
controversy not controversy but like a
lot of people don't like orco that was
their least favorite part of he-man and
the masters of the universe
like he's silly and stupid and he ruined
it it could have been cool show without
him
and there are people who absolutely love
orco generally people who came into it
as kids
and and like dorco as a child
we decided to like let's make orco
so beloved that people will get him as a
tattoo
like let's let's let's take this
character and
jump him up yes he powers up a bit
but everything about his story is so
compelling
and heartbreaking and it'll get under
your skin in a really moving way
we play orco like the kid in the
audience the idea is orco is the little
kid in the group
so he's a kid's way into the show kids
of course have power fantasies about i
want to be as strong as he-man with the
power sword i won't be strong like teela
but you know they eventually identify
the character that they're closest to
and that is orco he's kind of played
very like childlike
and so we do the same thing and like you
know from from
little orcos mighty trees grow that's
all i can say
um yes you'll love what we do with orco
um joshua
m quirk josh corkey says he man is a
boss
when will we see him in skeletor in a
relationship
well i hope i'm understanding this
correctly
um they've been in a relationship for
nearly 40 years
man uh that's kind of what our series is
about
these two and how this war never ends
and stuff like that so
we play that and of course we do in our
storyline we get to
cross our characters over not just for
fights although the fights are stunning
you finally get to see skeletor and
he-man
cross swords or or across the power
sword with the havoc staff
you'll see people get stabbed um you you
know it's pretty intense so the physical
fights the physical relationship between
them
we get to do more than they got to do in
the kids cartoon in the 80s but
for the conversational relationship
between them
there are there are a couple really
wonderful skeletor
adam skeletor he-man scenes
like that we never got to see in the old
show and stuff
because they've got this relationship um
and you know i'm not saying like
they love each other or anything like
that nobody will ship
he-man and skeletor i assure you but you
know they got a bond
and that's kind of a little bit about
what our what it's
kind of a little bit what our series is
about trust i'm being obscure
um okay
uh mingle 27 says do you think the new
series will have a bigger impact on
those who grew up with the original
or new fans uh for younger and haven't
seen anything
um i honestly well the the whole show
started as a fan service show
like hey man this is for the kids who
grew up watching masters of the universe
and stuff
and bought the toys so
uh going into it that's who originally
it was designed for
then as we were into it we were like
wait a sec
we could make this four quadrant kids
could get into this
because my um idea was
damn my idea was that
i went see raiders the lost ark with my
father and that day i saw
not my father but the man boy the boy
who my father was before he became a man
my dad had always been stoic dad type
dad to me
and then at raise the lost ark he turned
into a kid he was like oh my god this is
the kind of movie i used to see all the
time when i was a kid
they call them cliffhangers and then it
would end and we'd have to come back the
next week this is amazing they're doing
a cliffhanger don't you understand
like he was so engaged with me normally
he was fairly quiet guy but he was like
so excited i want that experience
for people watching masters of the
universe revelation i've had that
watching marvel movies you know with my
kid or my wife going oh let me explain
stuff to you
this gives the audience a chance to be a
storyteller as well
because you know somebody who knows the
material and goes way far back with it
we'll be able to answer questions to
anybody you know so the same way i
watched one division with my wife and
she'd be like
i don't understand what does that mean
and i'm like pause let me tell you
man because i've seen every marvel movie
there is and read all the comic books
so same thing here you can watch this
show with a masters universe virgin a
motu virgin
kids who've never seen it a boyfriend
girlfriend who's ever seen it husband
and wife who's never seen it your
parents who bought you the toys but
never watched or maybe just know passing
familiarity and stuff
um and everyone can like dive
into it like you know it's it's
incredibly rewarding
if you've been a longtime fan but if
you're like i have a passing familiarity
or even if you don't know it at all
you're going to be able to kind of sink
into it and stuff and so
i think it's going to work like
gangbusters for anyone growing up on
this stuff
but i honestly feel like the bonding
agent
between parent and kid is gonna bring in
that young audience i mean number one
it's colorful like kids can watch it
it's high adventure it's not too scary
and stuff like that
so you know it's a cartoon kids get into
cartoons at least they did when i was a
[ __ ] kid
but also on top of that i feel like it's
a very engaging cartoon i don't know if
this helps but
uh sarah's kids watch the show her boy
was watching the show and he was like
i want to know what happens next can we
get the next six and she's like i think
i know a guy
so he you know and he was like i was
like well he likes it because you know
you play tila
and she's like no he was not interested
in me in the least she's going he just
loves the show he thinks it's awesome
so i think it's going to work for kids
as well so i think it'll have
an impact on if you if you know any of
this and love any of this and have ever
loved it collected the toys
this whole series is a [ __ ] love
letter to you
if uh you're brand new to it all i think
you'll be shocked at how
easily you can sink into it how easily
you could fall down
the rabbit hole with us man you'll have
the power damn it
um okay uh tyler hanley says how much
were the original toys referenced in
creating the characters looks
for the show uh very much so tyler um
because this is a mattel television
production so it's all predicated on the
toys
more than the cartoons that ever
happened so more so
than the filmation cartoons uh
revelation is
is built on the world of the toys more
so than the 2002 mike young productions
ours is leans heavily into the mattel
because mattel owns what it owns and
stuff so and it's mattel televisions
they want to do their version
now luckily the figures and the
filmation cartoon kind of looked similar
because the designs were
very similar and stuff so um
you know the the world of like okay what
are they gonna look like
it's pretty easy it's like well we'll
make him look like the figures looked
and you know that's kind of what the
cartoon looks like as well
the big thing was the vehicles because
i'd written in the landshark bashasaurus
everything and stuff
win raiders and you know the boys pat
and adam are directors
like scanned in toys like they didn't
just do a drawing of it like
it's a scanned-in version of your
childhood toy you know and mattel was
very happy about that
any time we leaned into the toys which
was like everything we did
or any time we were like oh this could
be a new toy they were like yeah
yeah like yeah more of that or that less
of everything else
less nihilism more toys you know so
it's it's very much based on the line of
toys
um [ __ ] g [ __ ] [ __ ] ouija says
i'll watch either way but is the show
mainly about
tila instead of adam um
no um tila's in it and she plays a big
part as i've been saying
from the beginning um but just like in
every episode of
uh even he-man and the masters of the
universe the filmation show
she's right there next to he-man either
next to adam
protecting him or fighting side-by-side
with he-man so she's a big character
she plays prominently in our story line
uh
as well i would not go so far as to say
it's a tela show this is a masters of
the universe show
it's not called he-man in the masters
universe because filmation owns that as
previously established
but it covers all of the characters and
tila is a big part of it particularly
with the storyline
that we're kind of tipping our hat to
from uh the old filmation show and any
true fan knows what i'm talking about
so um yes uh tila's in it
but it's very much about he-man as as
somebody on the internet much smarter
than me pointed out
uh justice league zack snyder's justice
league or even
you know justice league uh is about
superman
and superman you know is dead and really
pops in at the very very end that's not
what happens in
master of the universe of revelation but
you can
have a thing be about somebody you know
and
not have that character in every damn
scene
um he wasn't in every damn scene of the
cartoon that we're sequalizing
spiritually so
we didn't feel the need to do that as
well um but
he's our main character he's our
superman
he's our batman he's he's the big guy
however like people keep looking in the
wrong direction because they're like oh
i heard there's a t-list show me and
you know i'm once the once you see the
story trailer because everyone's seen
the teaser trailer
story trailer kind of makes it clear
what we've been
not saying for a long time
um you know and if you don't get it from
the story trailer then you'll get it
when you watch the show but
you know there's he-man's all
over this he's in every episode of the
show
and adam's in a lot of it as well
prince adam a very important part
of the he-man equation so again pretty
soon everyone's going to see everything
but like
the revelation will be revealed but um
no it's not a tila show
this goes back to uh somebody had uh put
up a
tweet months back and they said uh i
heard from insiders
that in this show tila is a better
he-man than ximena she lasted proved
she's a better he-man than e-man
and she's got a girlfriend now very
specifically i
joked i was like hey where were you we
could have used your up in the writers
room but that's really not true at all
it's not that is not what the [ __ ]
show's about
um uh somebody then asked me like hey
man like uh
or i responded to another tweet where i
was like it's
it's he-man it's a he-man adventure it's
a he-man and he's the focus of the
[ __ ] story center of the story
it's absolutely true none of that is
[ __ ] untrue
so you know do i feel like it's a tela
show
it's as much a tila show as it is a
he-man show because it's a masters of
the universe show
everybody gets a lot of screen time and
and
you know it's just funny from where i
sit because
everyone's like pointing at one thing
and missing
the very obvious but
maybe they'll find it um but yeah
it's masters the universe kids all of
the characters
all of them stop stop
looking at just one thing you're missing
a very big part of
all this but you know you'll see when
you see it um okay
um carlos fandangos will end with carlos
he says
what was your favorite he-man character
and how have you changed them
changed them for the new show if at all
i mean skeletor was my favorite
character hands down but you don't
change a character like skeletor you
lean into everything that character is
about
but you get mark hamill to do his voice
and take it to like the next dimension
so i loved skeletor going in and you
could see in all the skeletor dialogue
like i
whether i'm credited with writing the
episodes or not i write on every episode
as a story editor i came up with the
entire story and then people wrote
separate episodes but
i come on top of them that sounds
dirtier than i meant it but uh i
follow them and you know sometimes i
have to follow them based on notes i got
from netflix sometimes i follow them
based on my own taste where i'm like i
don't like that but i would rather do
this
so you know i got to write on uh every
uh single episode and stuff
and um the uh
you know skeletor dialogue um in every
episode whether i've written
whether i'm credited with writing the
episode or not went through my filter
because i was writing it the whole time
for mark even before we talked about
casting it in my head i was like this
mark campbell
is definitely going to be mark you know
you need the joker to play [ __ ]
skeletor that's for damn sure
so i was kept writing and rewriting
everyone's skeletor to stick it into
mark's voice and stuff so skeletor going
in
was my favorite character uh coming out
i'm a big fan of he-man uh now
he-man for me was always like the least
interesting character when i used to
watch the show
because you know it's just the guy with
brute strength who could do everything
he's superman essentially
you know and superman is tough character
to write for because
he is so powerful and at the end of the
day unless he's fighting jesus or
kryptonite
superman's gonna win so in telling the
story we tell
of he-man and more importantly prince
adam
i fell in love with that character like
i realized he's a superhero he just
doesn't wear a suit
he doesn't wear a costume he just he's
nipples out barbarian
chested but he is absolutely a superhero
as
all the earmarks of superman and that's
kind of
how we wrote him in the show just noble
like got a real good heart and you know
but he's a boy so there's the shazam
element
to it as well so adam became
one of my favorite characters he-man as
well of course
but adam particularly became one of my
characters um
his noble heart just like makes my eyes
well up
um but uh evil in man that was the
shocker
that she became one of my favorite
characters too so i remember asking
teddy early on in the process ted
beasley over at netflix i was like
who's your favorite character and he
goes oh i love evil lynn i was like what
i was like no one's an evil lynn fan man
and he's like i am i love that character
i think she's got depth and she's got
levels and stuff like that
so in telling the story we tell for
revelation i
too like fell in love with with eva lynn
with you know it certainly helps when
you have uh lena heady
or heady uh doing the voice cersei
herself
[ __ ] rocking the [ __ ] out of evelyn
let me tell you something right now if
they ever do a live action
masters universe they now they have to
hire lena because she has defined the
role wait until you see what she does
and what she did with it made me really
fall in love with that character but i
fell in love with them all i love these
characters
so much um you know some people online
have been like yeah
[ __ ] like that like let me tell you
something right now i
i guarantee you i've watched more he-man
than you ever have in your entire life
you know it's not a challenge you're not
going to win anything if you're right or
wrong and [ __ ] but like
aside from watching it when i did in
real time when i was a kid
i re-watched it again going into this
because i did not want to [ __ ] this up
man
i said no way i never go into your
superhero movies
because i'm like that's too much
pressure man you can [ __ ] that up and
then the whole audience hates you
i'd rather just be the guy that watches
him and points out the [ __ ] that's wrong
and [ __ ] like that put no skin in the
game
but this time i put skin in the game and
it was with the unlikeliest character
if you had asked me 10 years ago if i
ever thought some of the best work i
ever did in my life would be done with
the character of he-man
i'd be like yeah what am i making jokes
jay and sam bob have a he-man riff in it
that's something like the star wars like
yeah how could that happen
and now i know how it could happen man i
stepped out of my comfort zone
and i jumped into a world that i was
familiar with
but uh also not achingly so um you know
for years i remember going like
man chris nolan made a great [ __ ]
batman movie and he's not even like the
world's biggest batman fan
you don't even have to be man you come
to love these characters though
deeply with your entire being and so i
love the motu family i love the i love
duncan i love tila
cringer orco all the relationships the
sorceress became like such an amazing
character i've never really liked
sorceress when i watched the show in the
80s
love the sorceress now certainly helps
that you know she's it's susan iseberg
doing her voice the voice of wonder
woman and stuff but
how she's written now and and it's not
like we created anything new for the
sorceress it was all there in the
masters of the
of the universe mythology and lures
already established by mattel
so you know i've i've fallen in love
with all these characters
um and and even more so watching the
shows
come to life but uh yeah hands down i
would say going in i was like skeletor
it's all about skeletor
and coming out i'm like adam and evil in
that's that's to me that's the heart
of what we did with revelation um
kids you're going to see it soon july
23rd on july 24th
we're going to drop um that sounds very
hip
um on here on the youtube channel uh a
series
called the masters of the universe
revelation
celebration celebrating the writers
behind each episode where i sit down and
talk about the writing of each episode
with the writer of each episode man so i
sit down with dia
with uh mark with tim and with eric
so you'll watch that that'll happen july
24th first off
july 23rd at midnight
get your ass to netflix and consume all
five episodes of masters of the universe
revelation you will
enjoy yourselves i promise you then if
you want to know more
jump back to the youtube channel here
youtube.com kevin smith
and watch the commentary tracks with me
and the writers man
but uh for the time being thank you for
giving me the questions
uh wish we could have got more but we
got some more than i was thinking about
and uh i'll see you for the commentary
tracks man masters universe uh
revelation celebration until then i'm
kevin smith
saying you have the power